hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess
uh it's uh it's a brilliant game from
the previous round one of the best games
of the previous round uh vasily
vancouver vs vladimir kramnik
and it features one of the most exciting
openings
in chess altogether the the dragon
sicilian uh
and well let's just dive straight into
it so kramnik with
the white pieces opens with e4 and it's
going to be a very very long theoretical
struggle
uh but when when is it that it's not
uh so c5 knight to f3 d6 and
d4 so striking in the center we have c
characters knight captures and the
knight to f6
we have knight to c3 uh and now g6 at
the dragon variation of the sicilian is
on the board and now bishop to e3
we have bishop to g7 and f3 the
beginning of the
so-called yugoslav attack we have knight
to c6 and now queen to d2
and something bobby fischer has said
once about
setups like the dragon sicilian like the
pirates defense and something that is
just too easy to play for white white
will just uh
set up this uh battery with queen to d2
bishop e3 play h4 g4 h5
uh and uh yeah that's a game over or at
least that's how bobby fischer put it so
let's see
if this is in fact still so in 2020.
uh here at vasily castles and vladimir
castle's queen side
uh and the immediate d5 striking in the
center
so for fulfilling the the dream of the
uh sicilian player
uh he captures knight captures in the
now knight captures on c6 so
this is all uh the the most often played
line
b captures and now bishop to d4 uh
offering a trade of dark square bishops
and of course
black declines this this is a very uh
very important piece
the so-called dragon in this variation
uh
bishop the c5 now attacking the rook
here and vasily just plays bishop to e6
he offers a
an exchange sacrifice here and although
it can
it can't really be captured in 11 games
that are in the database where this
position was reached uh
uh white only didn't lose one of those
11 games so it's uh
not the best way to go black keeps the
bishop fair he has the very nice rook
coming to the open b
file the knight is excellent he plays
the queen can easily enter the game
so it's not something you want to play
even in classical let alone in rapid
where you don't have all that much time
so here
knight to e4 by kramnik grabbing hold of
the d6 square
and now uh uh rook to e8 just getting
the rook out of harm's way although
uh black's position is so active that he
can even offer it once again
uh because black really doesn't care
about the exchange sacrifice here
and there are some very tricky lines
like c4 you attack the knight to rook e8
and then if you capture capture black is
still very happy
even with a peace sacrifice here because
i mean so many open lines with such a
powerful bishop pair and central control
everything is possible here for black so
just rook e8
not going for anything too crazy and now
finally
vladimir starts uh what bobby fischer
recommended all those years ago
h4 we have h6
a very a very nice setup by black as
you can always expect g4 and g5 so you
can push h5 or if
g4 h5 you can push g5 so you can always
uh
block the uh the pawn structure uh on
the king side
you do not want to open up any files
here so g4 by kramnik and now
just queen to c7 continuing development
and now the other rook can also enter
the game and here uh
well you could play h5 h5 has been tried
many times and black never really had
any
any problems with it you can even go f5
you can again block it with the g5
so kramnik here decides to go for g5 and
now vasily just blocks it with h5 and
he's
very happy with how things uh are going
for him
now the most common move here is bishop
to c4 so we are all
still in in deep theory here uh but
vladimir gus for queen to e1 it's a
much rarer move in this position and
now comes uh knights to f4 uh the knight
will be
will be excellent here as it really
controls this light square bishop also
prevents him from just developing it to
h4 trying to trade off
it for for this light square bishop and
this light square bishop
is very strong attacking that a2 pawn
you don't uh
even though you've now opened up the
diagonal you you don't necessarily
want to capture here like right away uh
so bishop to d6
uh challenging the queen queen to b6 and
bishop back to c5 here vasily goes back
queen to c7
uh and now uh there is one game in the
database where queen the c3 was played
but here we have uh
c4 and it is now as of move 21 that we
have a completely new game
so let's see how uh let's see how vasily
deals with this
uh sorry about that uh we have bishop to
d5
immediately grabbing that central square
preparing to eliminate
this knight as it is a very strong piece
at some point you might get a knight f6
check then maybe some
some lines would open up so here uh
while you could capture it again giving
black this massive center
doesn't really do all that much for you
the knight is now defending the bishop
after it moves you either capture the
bishop or if the king moves
you're just going to eliminate the
knight and black's entire position falls
apart so here
we have bishop to d6 once again by
kramnik queen to b6
and again bishop to c5 so a nice
repetition of moves queen back to c7
and now uh kramnik goes for rook to h2
he wants to
set up his rook to help out with the
defense of the second rank as
the white king will also be under siege
uh if
bishop to d6 was played once again it's
hard to say if vasily would be happy
with a repetition here queen b6
bishop to c5 or he would play queen b7
off for a full piece and just continue
continue the attack here as black
definitely does have compensation here
so instead rook h2 was played and now
comes
bishop captures an e4 eliminating this
knight
and now before recapturing bishop to b6
first we have queen to c8 and
now uh queen captures an e4 uh hoping to
get this c5
move in if you get c5 in you've cemented
the bishop on d6 which would be very
nice you open up the
this diagonal for the light square
bishop which would be extremely
important
and of course vasily knows chess a bit
too much to allow that so he pushes c5
himself
now you don't have c5 your light square
bishop stays here the knight
nicely dominates the slide square bishop
uh and
black's position is is is just very
pleasant to play so here
uh vladimir goes for b4 yeah his point
is he wants
vasilie to capture and then he wants c5
he really wants to play c5 here
uh but uh vasily of course not
interested he plays bishop captures an
f8
and now kramnik just captures on c5 uh
b5
maybe also is playable uh just uh uh
starting to push those pawns on the
queen side he goes for this capture
but vasily of course doesn't care about
this bishop he he just wants to keep
these pawns here so now white will have
to spend at least two moves get this
pawn to
c6 and only then this pawn to c5 to free
up the the light square bishop
so queen to a6 now getting the queen
into the into the game
now it's uh well lucky for white that
the rook is already here
rook to b2 uh as you are probably
expecting rook to be eight
to show up at some point and now queen
to a3
uh pinning the rook here we have king to
b1
uh unpinning uh and now uh bishop
captures on d6 we have c
captures on d6 and now it could be a
problem if these pawns start marching
forward
however rook ate the b8 and already uh
chugi is threatening mate on b2 so you
have to do something about this queen to
c2 is one option
however kramnik doesn't want to go to
such a passive square with the queen he
really likes his queen on uh
on e4 so instead he goes to rook to b7
defends this way and why not or with
this rook
regarding the entire b file it's not not
an issue for white or or maybe it is
uh so here rook eat a d8 by one
uh just going for that that pawn here
now there's a double attack on the pawn
uh and here well you could push it to
the d7 right away then
knights the e6 could be a very nice idea
just controlling that c5 square
white will not be able to cross it uh so
instead
vladimir decides to give up a pawn to
dislodge the black queen from such an
active square and only then continue
with
d7 so this is what happens he pushes c5
now these are two connected pass pawns
and there's really no option here you do
you do need to capture on c5 which is
what what chooky does we have
queen captures on c5 and now d7 and now
it's uh
it's a pretty pretty tough position uh
to be in
for uh for black as uh oh sorry for
white as white is now completely busted
here
but it's hard to realize why and yes
we've reached the position from the
thumbnail
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for
vasily while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting a move
with the knight back as vasili usually
does
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to d5 and
this is a beautiful move a brilliant
move as now the queen no longer guards
the rook so there's the threat of rook
captures on b7
which is a pretty big threat in itself
but there's an even bigger one
knight the c3 with a monster royal fork
here
so you can't defend against both threats
uh point is if if you capture
on b8 uh then ju sorry if you capture
mba then just
you deliver check queen to a king to a1
and queen c3 is now checkmate
uh on the other hand after this knight
to d5 if you capture the knight here
then the rook is still undefended just
through captures on b7 check
the queen controls the the entire c file
king here and this is again
checkmate so uh kramnik did the only
thing he could
uh to try and uh stay in the game but
it's not uh it's not all that easy he
played queen captures on d5
but now this requires him to give up the
exchange and now it's a bit of a
different story so queen captures on the
e5
rook captures on d5 and now rook
captures on b7
with check king to c2 and now comes rook
d captures on d7 uh kramnik recap
captures on e5 and now uh the uh
situation on the board is
four pawns each and uh vasily is up the
exchange so here he just played rook to
d4
going after the h4 pawn and the white
cannot defend this pawn or rather you
can but you have to trade rooks and if
you trade rooks it's just game over
so here it was in this position on move
38 that vladimir kramnik resigned the
game
and what what a victory for uh for
vasily manchuk uh to take down kramnik
like this with the black pieces
in none other than the the dragon
sicilian
so it was a it was also a very exciting
match the entire match was pretty crazy
uh vasily won the second game as well
and then vladimir had to win two games
on demand he was able to win the third
game
but then in game four uh vasily again
won with the black pieces so he took the
the full
three points against vladimir kramnik
and i will show the standings now
uh just in case i will not have time for
any more uh to show any more games from
the previous round although there is one
more game i will show for sure
uh so let's check it out so these are
the standings after round seven
uh from uh from chess24 uh magnus
carlson in first place with 20 points
daniani pon issue with 18 anish geary uh
in third place with 14 points
then vladimir kramnik with 12 peter
swiddler with 11
uh vasily went to uh in sixth place with
nine then boris girlfriend with seven
vishanantan anand uh
with six points peter lecker with five
and ding lyran in last place with three
points
definitely not his tournament uh
yesterday he again
lost uh some games uh due to uh
connection issues which is i mean which
is just terrible
so yeah uh once again uh that's the game
i do hope you enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank david weinreid
mark poitras lucas florec chez mike and
venkat subramani for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the legends
of chess
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day